and i think that the statistics is ten
percent more or less
one out of ten one out of nine ai
projects or aipoc actually reach
production
actually become profitable now that's a
groundbreaking number it's it's it's
just
crazy welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with leomi tech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech
artificial intelligence let's talk about
anything and everything relating to
artificial intelligence with roy
mercedes cto of beyond minds
as a leading ai pioneer and global
visionary with extensive innovation
experience in various industries
dr mecca has co-founded beyond minds to
bridge ai theory to practice
with the vision to create the first
enterprise ai system
that is universally applicable and
easily adaptable
he is passionate about fostering a
data-driven culture using ai as a
transformational catalyst to address
complex regulatory operational and
business intelligence challenges
before founding beyond minds dr meches
held a number of positions in high-tech
companies and academia
and conducted research focused on the
intersection of computer vision and deep
learning
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm good thank you for having me how are
you doing
i i'm doing fantastic thank you for
being with me dr roy messes
a phd from the tiffany on a lecture
a computer vision and deep learning all
around it sounds like a guy who is
pretty passionate about
everything to do with artificial
intelligence but even more interestingly
than being passionate about ai being
passionate about this idea of
theory versus practice and how do we
combine these two worlds
into the into 2021 when practically
ai is relevant for any field yet who
knows
how the hell it is was supposed to be
implemented aside from putting it on the
slide deck to raise the valuation a
little bit
so tell me a little bit about your
background
and and why you're so excited about ai
in general
yeah sure so thank you for the warm
introduction i think it's the first time
someone called me doctor so it's a
definitely a good start for the
conversation and then talk about myself
for a second
um so um yeah so yeah about about myself
uh i was an air traffic controller in
the israeli air force
um and after that i i did my bachelor
and master's in biomedical engineering
and during my master thesis i was
dealing with
uh some computer vision of brain
m alive and then i fall in love with the
field of computer vision and
ai and specifically and and two years
after i found myself doing a phd in the
technion
um um or in in in general computer
vision
um i was doing research in
diversity set of problems around
computer vision
uh read so many papers and and
got in love with with the field totally
um
so that's you know that's my background
before i started the company before we
founded the company
uh me and and wrote them um
and and yeah that's that's the main
background i guess
and so a lot of people that go and
specialize in ai computer vision they
then
take this you know expertise and
translate it into you know a specific
problem that perhaps they're
very interested in or curious and you
decided to do something different with
your understanding
of ai so talk to me about this
dissonance from
theory to practice right so so
we founded beyond mines with a very
significant vision
and uh gotem came from uh
one of the defense companies in israel
with some practice
experience in in nlp and and putting
solutions in production
and we both identify this gap between
the amazing
amazing not other words theory and
research around ai three percent of all
research paper a year are about ai
that's that's that's a crazy number
and while this is amazing and i love
writing papers and i love reading papers
there is a big gap to actually value and
practice
if you go to mckinsey gardener
mit this with sloan
british
name it just name it whatever server you
will go and
look at you will find a systematic
failure around
bringing ai into production or
bringing profit out of ai and i think
that the statistics
is 10 more or less one out of 10
one out of nine ai projects or aipoc
actually rich production actually become
profitable
now that's a groundbreaking number it's
it's it's just
crazy that so much money is invested in
ai
and by the way if you look for example
at the fortune 1000 companies in the us
okay 1 000 companies the biggest
companies
in the us on average they invest 50
million dollars around ai a year
that's 50 billion dollars just in the us
by the fortune 1000 companies
well 87 or 90
of that money is a waste of money
it it's it won't lead into roi and and
that's what we're trying with the
mission to solve
bridging this ai theory lab
ai into the production whether it
requires system
envelopes monitoring security
compliance and many many other elements
uh stability robustness
retraining of the models there's so many
elements of ai in production that need
to be taken
take care of uh and and that's what
we're doing
at beyond minds and and that's why we
founded the company
so i'm i'm hearing you hint that you
know part of the reason that these 90
of these of the papers then don't get
translated into positive roi is all
is not just because the the ai may not
be relevant for the company but it's
also because
the whole the whole supply chain that
will bring the ai to productization
that part is is still not easy to
maintain or to or to create yet right
so i think i think it's a great question
and
i usually distinguish between the
organizational
challenges that maybe still exist into
the
technology of tech related challenges
and i think while if you go three years
back around i don't know 2018 where
most companies decided to build the
center of excellence and bring
ai and they stuck into
lack of talent and strategy
and and and vendor selection and
business alignment
and find the right starting point right
these are challenges but i think today
at mid 2021
after a a pandemic that gave a boost to
digital
hedge funds formation etc i would
say that most organizations let's say
around 70
in my assessment and some surveys
already
passed this maturity level and they have
data lakes and data flows and data
breaks and snowflakes
and whatever you just named right and
they brought platform and they hired
every phd that came from stanford
uh uh into into their company but
okay now you have phds sits in the lab
you brought them data
and they train the model and then what
can you just take this model and put it
in production
the answer is is clearly not
right and so you come in with the
experience and you're working with
companies
to make it happen what what do you what
what does it take
you know why is this why is this a
difficult problem to solve
that required somebody with a phd from
the testimonial to come and help them
figure out what is the right process to
go and do it
so so first of all it's required much
more than a phd from the technical it
requires
a company with with a lot of very
many very talented people engineers
researchers
data scientists uh production experience
and we invested in the last two and more
years
thousands of human hours uh into
building a platform that will enable
this uh uh this path
right and it's not a development tool i
think you know the landscape of ai is
very interesting and
as i see it you can cut it more or less
into
three pieces there are vertical
companies amazing companies that
solve a very specific problem and maybe
they use ai as part of the technology
but they solve a very specific problem
and their product can be delivered off
the shelf
and then you have um development tools
again companies that developed a a
a tool a platform maybe also the cloud
providers you can count on this area
aws and google and azure have amazing
tools for developers
but these are all developer tools and
and then
there is beyond minds and and and some
other companies but
we are focusing on business on
delivering business values
solution with ai and
and and our platform is the enabler to
break the failure rate that i
described in the beginning right so we
are coming with a third
element uh that enable companies
okay i want their in production i want
it fast
and i want better success rate so you
can come to beyond minds and
use our uh platform as an enabler
and we're going to customize for you a
silver bullet solution
now one of the key observation
observation of our model is that
ai and data related problem are
characterized by
high specificity they're specific in the
needs and requirements and the
business elements and the constraints
and the data
and most of them i would say 80 percent
of the market
cannot be solved by an off-the-shelf
product
and if it can it's not a room for us
there is an
amazing product that you can take off
the shelf but if it can't
and in many cases currently it can't
companies usually go inside to the
center of excellence
and they they meet 18 months delivery
time to production and 10
success so we are providing an
alternative path
to that uh awful cycle
so now take me let's play mind game and
take me you know five years down the
line
where practically you know all of these
tools are democratized enough
that you know you can customize them or
create models in
in much higher rates and you can either
fail faster or you can just
have better evaluation of the success
rates later where does beyond mines fit
into this
place where the world is moving to
that's a that's a very complex question
to to
forecast five years ahead with the with
the speed of ai development
but i think what we're trying to do uh
is to accelerate
the ai adoption and enable companies to
bring more and more
ai into various areas of the business
we're not trying to solve one specific
use case for a company we're trying to
help them to do
ai transformation and bring use case
organization wide right um and our
platform enable
a host or or an enabler
of organization wide ai adoption
right including the monitoring that
requires and
data connectivity and stability
and and the compliance element um and
and the main area that we that we're
working on
are dealing with mission critical
problems
right that requires a lot of effort
right i think an interesting point is
that that i see today the trend
in ai is that the ai use cases are
shifting from
what i call statistical use cases that's
okay if it's 80
accuracy of 82 accuracy okay it's not a
big deal take for example
netflix recommendation system okay
it can be better but it's already
bringing value and the customers are
happy with that
on the other hand if you are taking
defect detection of
a iphone manufacturing right you don't
want as
a as an oem that produce their iphones
that a bad iphone will leave the comp we
leave the the factory
right right same with i don't know um
an insurance company where you automate
claims automation you automate claims
with ai
you don't want to reject a claim for a
customer that
should be approved because that customer
is going to social media
and going to harm your business
significantly
on the other hand you don't want to
authorize a claim that should be
rejected
right so that case
is critical for the business right
and when you go into mission critical ai
and and i think that's the trend because
this is the real value that ai can bring
and take you know we look at lemonade as
an example
right how you do an amazing insurance
company with
small operation well so much of
it is automate and and and you have good
numbers
so it's possible but it's lemonade is a
technology company
to take i don't know uh um classic
anthem i don't know like hundreds of
thousand employees company and
and bring ai into a core
activity is much more challenging and
requires
human in the loop and trust and
compliance
and security and data governance and
stability
and and so many elements that need to be
considered
so of course it's not it's not easy to
take a poc
and just put it in production and do you
find that there is this
that you know the people that you're
working with do they understand these
limitations
you know at the end when when these
projects come about within the companies
and they're being pushed by these
different
you know figures within the company that
don't necessarily understand the
technology don't understand
that you know productizing a an ai model
is not the same as building out
another feature for the front end you
know lead flow
right do you find that there is this
proper communication rather than this on
this open-mindedness
it's definitely improving um and and
it's improving mainly in the line of
business people
so of course the technical people the ai
masters that are dealing with bringing
these solutions to production and
are facing these barriers daily but i
think
you see that the the line of business
the the people that are actually
responsible for the actually the
customers of these ai solutions
they understand more and more uh about
what ai can offer
what are the challenges what are the
risks
what is required from them i think you
know
like many other technologies ai
involved many business elements and
business decision
need decisions need to to take into
consideration and done
during the ai development it's just it's
it's it's
far from here is a data set gave me a
classifier let's put that in production
you're going to have different elements
that need to
to to be considered and work with the
business
side of the organization and i think
that that's collaboration and mindset
is is is improving significantly
right what would be what would be maybe
the one or two biggest tips you would
give to somebody within our organization
that is that is facing these challenges
or is
or or is or is trying to to to change
some mechanism
uh you know with ai what would be sort
of like
the big ideas that you're bringing
together from all the experiences you've
had so far with the onlines
okay so so i have several but let's
start with with the easiest one
don't do pocs i think poc is one of the
largest traps
around ai because the the gap between
the lab and production
is so loud that the poc is not even
relevant
you need to think about production
and all the requirements of the
production and how that's going to work
and solve that including the hardware
and how the human is going to be
involved with it
and what's going to if it's going to be
automated or human in the loop
and do you need to retrain the models in
production
and do you need to monitor the models in
and how you're going to have data drift
and how you're going to
face these data drifts in production um
and you know if you want i can give you
an example um
take care for detection for example okay
for these are very dynamic elements
right of course
you can like take five years ago all the
banks had rule-based
systems right and and worldwide systems
are defined by rules so of course fraud
become better and better
um i don't know take a stupid example
but uh
um you have a rule that a transaction
above five thousand dollars
raise a flag okay so i will do four
thousand nine nine right
okay so you do a percentage from the
blah blah blah
okay so i will do um sub percentage
right
right and of course so this problem is
so dynamic
and even if you solve it with ai right
and you use historical data
okay so next month there will be a new
type of thought so you need to train
these models
in production consistently that's a
super challenging problem even if you go
to the
most advanced state-of-the-art research
there is no
clear solution on how to do the training
of models
definitely not in production um
and and then okay a famous element
um of ai is that when it fails it fails
very silently
right um i love to i love to give an
example that
okay you build your dog versus cat
classifier and then you got an image of
vegeta
the model will say that it should it's a
dog or a cat right
and it won't tell you that he don't
think that he don't show
that i have doubt um
right it will classify it as a dog and
the soft max of the deep learning
amazing model will give you 99 percent
accuracy
probability right and it's far from
probability
so for example confidence estimation or
uncertainty estimation as the research
community call it
is a critical element in mission
critical problems
okay right so how you put confidence
estimation and what is going to
do with your latency and have those
requirements
okay so you have confidence but then
another element
that that you need to solve is is what
you do it
out of distribution examples right for
example okay you
you have the data that you trained your
models
amazing images of cats and dogs right
but you will get a weird
image that is completely out of the
distribution
okay and and even if you have
uncertainty
you still won't be able to detect this
out of distribution example
so all of these elements must be solved
in production if you're
talking about mission critical problems
and
and it's far behind the model okay the
the model
and and i think that's that's maybe the
takeaway that i can give to
to to researchers the model is important
right but it's only one single component
the heart of the system out of a
holistic system that needs to be
built to solve production problems
that makes a lot of sense and they you
know from personal experiences i
couldn't agree more
it always you know shocked me how much
work we put into the model but then
the actual you know the the living
breathing system that orchestrates it
is is infinitely more more complex and
and it requires a thinking that just
isn't done initially because you don't
give that enough respect to that so i
completely appreciate that that that
understanding roy are you ready for
three
short and fun questions wow yeah
i hope so let's do it favorite subject
in school k to 12.
okay so when i was at uh
seventh grade i have i had a uh
carpet carpetery uh clap
and and today as a hobby
that's like the best thing i love to do
just bring me a saw
and a hammer um and then i
i just bought a jigsaw um and i will be
happy
just give me wood i will build something
i love it
okay one of your role models
professionally or personally
okay that's it that's a a very tricky
one so
my first intuition was to say michael
jordan because i
love the mentality of the teamwork
that michael jordan bring with him um
i think there is one very nice quote and
probably i i miss
i i'm doing a mess with the quote but
it's something like uh
um individuals win games
but teams uh win um
um the league right the the
championship yeah and
and i couldn't agree more like uh you
know we started with that okay i have a
phd
i did a lot of research but i i'm
nothing
without an amazing team that support me
and and build the company
uh with me uh shoulder to shoulder as a
team
and i think in basketball this teamwork
is is so nice
um and and you know michael jordan and
his team
right what is michael jordan without
dennis rodman and peeping actually
nothing i love it
last question three words that you would
choose to describe yourself
okay it's related somehow to the
previous question teamwork
uh creativity and execution
sounds it sounds perfect teamwork
creativity and execution in that order
thank you very very much uh stay safe
and stealthy thank you for sharing with
me your insights from the field
i i'm practicing them on a daily basis
and and i can see how
how incredibly challenging it is but
what's exciting for me about this is
that it's just the beginning and we're
just observing how organizations are
understanding this shift
and mindset that we need to do and to
have and it just sounds like everything
you're working on and you're thinking
about
is just becoming exponentially more and
more relevant as time moves on
and we're just in the beginning so it's
really exciting
definitely i was happy to share my my
knowledge and
and thoughts about that and thank you
for uh hosting me
take care bye bye bye
[Music]
you